okay because here's the thing right if
he was like man yeah right cool but suck
on my tongue yeah
that is very different I'll be a little
boy
yo I don't know how they said like those
two things are different yeah and so
this is the other thing that they were
saying they go okay but you guys
understand
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast uh genius brain
is every Sundays at 12 p.m if you're a
brand new listener where the [__] have
you been
dolly
out here kissing little baby sticking
your tongue out you little sick freaks
that is probably one of the most
heinous videos I've ever seen in my life
and I couldn't believe what I was
watching bro he has to be suffering from
Dementia or some [__] like for him to
think that was okay to do like okay you
know what I mean so could I just say
this real quick and I mean no disrespect
to the Buddhist religion right this is
already sounding really bad whenever you
preface it with something like that I
mean absolutely no disrespect right yeah
so
me watching this video yeah there are
times where I catch myself where I say
oh I actually don't know what this is or
what this means so I was like what is
the Dalai Lama well let me tell you
something people
this is the most complicated [__]
religion I've ever read about In My Life
Buddhism is so [__] complicated I
hate it so [__] much this is what it
was I was reading I was trying to
understand okay what is what is the
Dalai Lama and they're like okay it's
it's a specific set of Buddhism called
Buddhism of the Yellow Hat what is the
Yellow Hat this is what was happening I
would read the the definition of what
I'm looking for and they would say 18
more words that I don't [__]
understand what it means it's just like
to keep scratching off and then like the
seven blah blah of Tantra and I'm like
what the [__] is Tantra yeah I look at
Tantra they go Tantra is the six forms
of the Buddhist palm or some [__] like
that I'm like you know I was there for
like three hours just going back in
information trying to understand what
the [__] first part is right you know
when you do stuff like that that's how
you end up like starting to look up
Dalai Lama and and the bet two girls one
cup
it keeps branching up into crazy [__]
and I was getting pissed like Mariel was
like looking at me and she goes why are
you so frustrated It's like because I
don't understand Buddhism yeah so
America was like listen when I was in
college this is what my professor says
Buddha Buddhism is nothingness and I'm
like okay get the [__] out of this room
too all right because you're not helping
me out either she said her professor
said Buddhism is a life of pain and I'm
like this is the dumbest thing I've ever
read about in my life but long story
short for this from what I've gathered
right
it's basically Avatar that's how the
Dalai Lama is chosen yeah and that's
what Avatar was based off since we're
you know this is how my brain works it's
the only way I can connect something
intelligent is to anime and cartoons
yeah so you know if you guys watch
Avatar right how is how is Aang selected
as the Avatar they
get a few objects to see which object
that this child chooses because the
object that the child chooses is from
the previous
um Avatar that's essentially what they
took off from this you know Tibetan
Monks or whatever whatnot and so the
Dalai Lama is chosen that way so the
Dalai Lama before he passes right
practices something called conscious
dying so this [__] just doesn't
die yeah lays down or figures out with
his other like servants and goes you
know what
I'm about to die right now you know and
then he consciously dies so he forces
himself to reincarnate right so before
that I'm not sure if this is exact I'm
gonna put a bunch of information on this
video because I'm not sure if I'm
regurgitating this correctly but if you
don't
consciously reincarnate you go into like
this thing and then you figure out where
you're going to reincarnate later but if
you consciously do it you end up in the
body of another person and that's what
the Dalai Lama does okay so yeah I
didn't know the specifics of The
Reincarnation part of it yeah so it
typically it takes about two to two to
three years in order to find the new
Dalai Lama because you don't know where
his body reincarnated he was found four
years later right and so you give them
the the item they choose the item if
it's correct of the previous Dalai Lama
and then his living servants have to
confirm other things in order for this
Dalai Lama to be accepted or to be for
to be legit that he's the real one yeah
it's a whole bunch of different steps
and this is essentially how this guy was
chosen and also you have to be a
pedophile
once you get a certain level of power
you have to touch babies apparently yeah
so this guy apparently is the most
famous Dalai Lama of all right right
Nobel Peace Prize winner yeah right he
also looks like John Amos
look at the big dowels yeah he visited
uh my college when I was in college what
the [__] yeah
are you too old yeah you were all legal
at that point you know so he was like
shave your mustache let me see
what was his AB where did he kiss this
kid
um I don't know I don't know where it
happened at but it was pretty disturbing
to like read that he told him to suck on
his tongue dog so okay so I started you
know when you read things right yeah now
because the internet is so crazy I have
to double check that's exactly what I'm
like I was like this cannot be clicky
[__] what kind of [__] onion you
know article is this you know and I open
it up and I see this video yeah and I'm
immediately disgusted yeah you have to
understand how much [__] up [__] we've
seen on the internet for me to look at a
video and go what the [__] is happening
and so the idea behind this right so a
lot so the people who are so there's
there's like this uh child protective
like Service Group out there they go
listen in tibetan culture they have this
thing where
sticking out your tongue is like a sign
of like a greeting right but they're
like yeah yeah but they said even that
yeah exactly that's a [__] stretch
that's a that's a big stretch right
there I'm like that's a bit of a stretch
yeah and so I guess what happened was
and once again I'll put this in the
video if you guys can see this
information because I don't know the
specifics really but the idea of
sticking out your tongue yeah happened
from I guess that was like this despotic
ruler that was a king that was
considered evil so that he had like a
Serpent's Tongue or black tongue so in
order for people to show that they're
not with the King they would stick out
their tongue and it became a form of
greeting now that is a fat [__]
stretch from here to suck on my toes
okay it's because here's the thing right
if he was like man yeah right cool buddy
that is very different come here little
boy
yo I don't know how they said like those
two things are different yeah and so
this is the other thing that they were
saying they go okay but you guys
understand the Dalai Lama is a
Reincarnation of like 17 Generations
you're judging him from times now you
have to judge it from the time for like
2 000 years ago because remember he's
actually that old hey but he lives in
modern times you know it doesn't matter
if he's 2 000 years old like he lives in
2023 bro and there was one article that
I was reading too with where you know I
guess people who are Avid followers of
him right we're like saying what he was
playing playfully with the child right
the child asked for a kiss I said no no
no no no no no no no he asked the kid
for a kiss don't [__] Gaslight us
there's an actual recording of the
[__] video he's over here touching
his face head doing the head thing yeah
kissing him oh you should kiss me here
yeah he goes now suck my tongue I was
like excuse me
yeah it's it's that's what I'm saying
like he has to be suffering from
dementia you know because the thing is
all right maybe he's been a pedophile
all along but now he's he's like losing
his his faculties a little bit and it's
just it's just it's seeping through the
cracks you know that [__] was [__]
wild man that was that was definitely uh
I can't believe they use the excuse like
he's actually like a gajillion years old
because he's reincarnated I mean they're
trying to they're trying
about whatever they can to make it seem
like it wasn't weird or it wasn't
strange like not a dog that was one of
the [__] strangest things I've seen
this year I still can't believe he
literally looks like the McDowell's
owner I'm [__] if I'm coming to
America he looks like John Amos bro if
anything else that John Amos died I'm
like that's where he reincarnated right
[__] there dude he's the old
[__] man that's what kind of
makes it creepier the fact that you know
he looks really good for his age though
he does he's like 90 almost 90. yeah he
does but he still looks pretty old
that's what happens when you begin
no no no that's what happens when you
want to be kissing babies but you've
been suppressing until 90.
he was like suck my tongue I'm like four
wait yeah there's there's no way to to
save that you know once that's out there
in the public like whether you read
about it you hear about it you see it
there's no way to save that there's no
way to excuse that that's [__] weird
and pretty [__] disgusting
um I don't know why he was looking at
that kid looked like he saw a long lost
lover and I did not like that [__] it
wasn't even one of the things like oh
this kid's really cute yeah that fool
look like he was in love with that
little boy and I don't [__] like it
yeah it's uh
there was definitely some Jeffrey
Epstein energy maybe that's that
[__] was on that list he was
definitely on that [__] list dude
it's weird watching like all like I've
been watching this oh dog I couldn't
watch this documentary all the way but
it was hard for me to kind of go through
it because you know I grew up going to
church yeah and there's this doc on
Netflix where there's this uh very
famous Korean Pastor right who I heard
of this guy when I was younger right but
you know I'm young because this is like
in the 80s so there was even before I
was born yeah but he's you know there's
a lot so if you guys don't know like
Christianity is very very prevalent in
Korea like when you drive around you
just see a bunch of crosses everywhere
churches are everywhere they got those
mega churches out there too Mega [__]
churches right and so whenever whenever
there's somebody who not everybody in a
church is good right so when there's
somebody who gets a hold of it that's
really bad they'll exploit people so
this guy was like the master manipulator
right because you already know what
happens when a cult right you join a
cult the end result is somebody's gonna
get their dick sucked that's just how it
happens I don't [__] know why but at
least that's the formula yeah you know
so this guy
was basically so powerful he was like on
TV everything and he was like a power
evangelist and basically he kind of
convinced people that he was the second
coming of Jesus Christ wow people there
goes people said that Jesus Christ was
coming again and he goes
here and people are [__] crying
clapping their hands in the beginning of
this doc right there's a girl who's
speaking Korean she said I believe she
was actually from Hong Kong but she went
over to to attend this church and then
become one of his disciples what's the
name of this talk I can't even remember
I was so disgusted but I'll send it to
you maybe you'll be able to watch it
because you didn't maybe grow up going
to church when you're a little kid yeah
so it made me feel really funny
um but the girl was just talking about
how he so he would record there's no way
they would have got this audio unless it
was him recording it so he will record
them [__] he would [__] all the girls
all these all these girls he's just
recording audio of it I think the video
and audio okay so there was like video
clips of girls like in the shower all
naked and obviously their faces were
their bodies blurred and they're telling
them to come in and shower with him yeah
and then there's other girls like she's
crying and she's talking about this but
he's talking to her in Korean and this
is the part that made me I was getting
heated yeah because he's like asking her
like how many times did she come like
did you come he goes I came like six or
seven times this girl's like 16 bro
[__] disgusting
yeah the thing is it's like you know the
people who are kind of susceptible to
that that cult uh setting and and kind
of getting involved and sucked into that
cult life
you gotta have some issues for sure
because like you know how do you get
convinced that he's another guy he is a
second coming of Christ you know what it
feels like he sells kimbap for a living
he's like keep top vendor on the streets
during the week on the weekend he's a
televangelist
who looks like a [__] dweeb dude and
he somehow convinced everybody he was
the second coming of Jesus Christ and he
was [__] these underage girls some
people just have the Gift of Gab man
they they just have that Charisma you
know they might not be a looker
necessarily but they're just able to
talk their way into people's lives and
and like basically grab them by the hook
and and own them pretty much right
Mariel when she was in Korea she told me
the story where you know there's a a a
Korean series that I watch that's I
think is very very good it's like a
thriller it's called and it's it's about
Korean religious cults and it's a whole
series it's not a documentary it's like
a draw it's like a drama Thriller it's
[__] nuts really [__] good
um
and essentially Mario when she was in
Korea like you'll see this when you guys
go to Korea
um in very popular busy areas you'll see
people try to you know evangelize yeah
yeah they're actually pretty common
um and so
and so Muriel's out there and this lady
approaches her and then she's basically
trying to convert Mariel right
and then she's like oh do you speak uh
Korean and she goes [__] Mariel's
goopy ass she's like speaking to her in
a broken Spanish because she doesn't
want to talk to her I think oh we have
somebody who speaks Spanish oh man I
think she wanted the chances bro yeah
there she goes then she starts speaking
in English yeah and then you know some
of them can speak English yeah and so
basically he said like oh Jesus Christ
is here on Earth right now and then
Mariel's like obliging them and she goes
well where where is Jesus Christ and
this lady comes out from the back it's
just old she goes it is me
it's this old Korean lady I am here and
Mariel busts up laughing yeah and then
she couldn't stop laughing because she
thought it was a joke yeah but dude
there's this woman has somehow amassed a
certain amount of followers how [__]
crazy is that [__] that's what I'm
saying man is like to most normal people
from the outside looking in that [__] is
[__] wild and it's crazy but you know
there like I said there are people who
are just susceptible that to that kind
of thing to get brainwashed get sucked
into it I don't know man maybe they had
some kind of trauma in their life and
then this helps I I can't explain it
what it is but one thing that I feel is
usually true in cases like this is those
people who become a part of those Cults
and and follow these crazy [__]
got some issues of their own got
something wrong with them you know and
they're looking for something to fix
them or fill a void or whatever but
you know if I was Mario I would have
done the same thing I would have talked
to them just for like sheer
entertainment
I do that sometimes I I know there these
people are nuts but I'm like I want to
see where this is going you know let me
let me see what this is about yeah Jesus
Christ was all [__] 70 year old
Korean lady who works with a kimbap band
selling kimchi yeah but that [__] was
[__] weird man like watching like
seeing that little because at first when
that video came out I don't think that
kid's face was blurred in certain
certain I was like that's not right yeah
but then they started blurring his face
after and it was like this young little
boy and I just he's 10 right he was 10
or something yeah he looked younger to
me yeah and I was so creeped the [__]
out yeah that's you know it's uh
it's pretty foul man when you anything
when it happens to kids things that
aren't supposed to happen to kids when
it happens
especially like I don't know for I think
I don't just speak for myself when I say
this it's deeply [__] disturbing you
know when we have like these school
shootings and elementary kids are
getting slaughtered that's it's
disturbing on a different level I'm not
saying the loss of like an adult life is
is any less uh you know important but
it's just like man kids should not have
to [__] go through something like
that you know
okay so I've been like staying away from
my school shooting stuff but there was
like another huge one right in Nashville
yeah do you know what happened with that
so he was a bank employee and he knew
that he was about to get fired so he
purchased a gun I think like a week
before and just decided he's gonna go in
there and shoot these people up you know
what what where was this at was that
elementary school the Nashville one oh
the Nashville oh so I thought you're
talking about the the most recent one
was I forgot where it happened that but
well there's another one yeah that just
happened this past week
God damn dude there's been a hun like
136 mass shootings already which four or
more people uh got killed I believe I
think there's been 136 this year already
holy [__] yeah it's [__] wild um no
yeah but the school one uh that one was
the uh the I think the female shooter
right the one where she like Shot
Through the Glass and came in holy no I
don't I didn't read up about any of that
[__] yeah so there's those were the two
big mass shootings that got headlines
over the past few weeks yeah but they
released the video of the one that
happened at the school and
ah bro like the body cam footage when
the officers are like you know going
through the halls and [__] like that and
then they have to blur a [__] small
little body on the
it's like oh
it's a [__] like eight-year-old
nine-year-old kid that's like that's
Lane you see these small little
backpacks and
it's just like dude
these kids should not have to [__]
ever ever in their life even think about
[__] going through something like
this you know who who did this and what
was the motivation that I don't know I
don't know what the motive was um with
that that's [__] crazy like when it
comes to like news like this right I've
read it so much and I'm not saying that
I'm trying to be somebody who's not
trying to be like actively involved and
you know no it's look man I I don't want
to [__]
honestly constantly find out about this
[__] either you just can't help it you
know that's why I'm like hazy on the
details of of that shooting and yeah
it's a woman shooter yeah yeah
um is this is this the first female Mass
shooter
that I don't know but but it might be
actually it might be 28 year old Audrey
Hill
once attended this school
yeah yeah that's right she did attend
the school yeah but I don't know I don't
remember what her motive was we've
talked about this multiple times on the
podcast the same thing that I always
[__] say to my cell phone I see this
like when is enough enough you know what
I mean how many more [__] children
need to die how many more things need to
be put into place to like quote unquote
prevent this type of [__] like there was
a lot of uh say like things of oh that's
why there should be only one door in and
out like they shouldn't have big window
I'm like no it just shouldn't be
happening period yeah these [__] kids
should not have an active shooter drill
like that's [__] crazy to me when we
were young bro we had earthquake drills
you know what I mean like we have fire
drills yeah we [__] go under the desk
you know we stop drop and roll these
kids today have [__] active shooter
drills my my friend told me like his
young daughter when he talked to him
about the [__] drills that they have
she called it the bad like the bad
person
um Trail or something like that yeah
when there's a bad person on campus this
is what they need to do I'm like yo bro
okay that's listen listen to this part
so it says wait National gender activist
slam dead naming Audrey Hill wait so
this person's uh trans
that I don't know what the [__] wait
hold on what the [__] is going on right
now I don't know about that I don't I
don't know if they were trans or not but
Audrey Hale a woman who's LinkedIn
profile states she prefers the name
Aiden and pronounced he and him gunned
down three teachers and three young
children before she was shot dead by
police
but he later referred so Nashville
police chief John Drake said during a
press conference that hill was a 28 year
old female that lived in Nashville area
who identifies as transgender but he
later referred to Hale as a trans woman
suggesting she was a man identifying as
a woman sewing confusion among reporters
gender identity Advocates accuse
mainstream Media news outlets with
scrambled to cover the story of Mr who
the [__] cares it's a [__] crazy
[__] who killed children and
teachers man who the [__] exactly you
[__] weirdo yeah they don't deserve
that type of [__] attention it's just
a weird thing right it's like so kids
died and the most important thing that
you give a [__] about is the dead naming
yeah are you [__] out of your mind
exactly it's like bro what the [__] are
you talking who cares if this one
individual got [__] dead name they're
a [__] psychopath how about exactly
that's the only [__] label they need
you know a crazy [__] who don't
honestly who don't like these people
don't even [__] deserve to get their
name put out in the Publications in the
news they don't deserve that type of
[__] attention let them [__] be
nameless don't [__] but you know
that's just my [__] gripe I'm sure
other people have the same right they're
like is this person trans I don't give a
[__] what they are yeah they're a
[__] shooter yeah [__] [__] leave
them nameless and leave them out of the
[__] head like [__] those people you
know I mean because the thing is they it
it inspires other crazy [__] to do
[__] like that because they see the
attention and the notoriety that these
people get once they do something like
that and then they get inspired by it
and then they do [__] copycat [__]
right
um but there was that and then the
shooting that I was talking about that
happened recently was a bank employee
and yeah he knew he was gonna get fired
and so he just decided all right I'm
gonna
go and [__] kill these people let me
tell you something man
it's just a paint job
what the [__] I mean most people quit
those jobs yeah his parents I guess or
now they were starting to speak out
about like kind of his mental illnesses
that he had or something but either way
like
I remember reading an article about it
like where he was as he was entering the
building or something apparently he told
like the first person this lady that he
saw it's like you need to get out of
here and then he still shot anyway
[Music]
yes I was like why why are you giving
the person a warning and then Blaster
yeah what the hell yeah I mean so I
think like this is where
many people kind of have problems with
gun laws right it's like okay so his his
parents said that he was mentally
unstable but somehow he got his hands on
fire an AR-15 you know which is pretty
insane right
you know from what I've kind of gathered
from a lot of people right even people
who were like gun rights activists I
think like the fine medium that uh gun
activists
who do believe in stricter gun laws they
say this they go yeah we should have
stricter gun laws like crazy people
should not be able to get their hands on
guns at all whatsoever and we do make it
way more difficult yeah I think for them
what they want also is like but once you
kind of pass all these tests for these
stricter gun laws you should allow us to
have the firearms that we want right
because if we are saying human beings we
should be able to have our AR-15s or
whatever as long as those laws are in
place yeah which that could be the happy
medium yeah I mean honestly that's
probably the best case scenario that's
like that like both you know that's
probably the best case scenario but
still unlikely yeah you know there's
just what is the idea of I wonder what
the holdup is on that like why why isn't
it a general consensus that you know
what like the Tesla so if you guys
haven't taken a test to obtain a legal
firearm I'm in California it's pretty
[__] easy like it's damn [__] easy
and there really isn't like
um
a psychoanalysis yeah yeah there isn't
any at all yeah to be honest with you
yeah I don't think there's a uniform
process across the country and it should
be it should be uniform right that's not
to say like a few people won't slip
through the cracks but if we can
minimize that that would be so much
better because there's too much [__]
money behind it bro like the NRA lobbies
too much they've they [__] line the
pockets of so many right-wing
politicians you know and whenever
there's money and power involved they're
gonna do everything they can to to
maximize that and keep growing it you
know and strict their gun laws mean
harder to sell them easily right and so
they don't want that they just want kind
of like enough in place to to kind of
save face and be like yeah we have these
protocols in place you know but then
once we're talking about kind of going
beyond that it's like oh well now you're
asking for too much you don't see that
video interview it was it's not Stephen
Colbert it's um
Jon Stewart was basically going head to
head with somebody who was a you know a
gun rights activist and he was basically
dismantling his [__] argument like
yeah right that's I mean that's what
that [__] guy does to anybody here
you know so [__] smart so [__]
smart and the thing is it's under this
comedic shell that he has right and so
it's kind of it's he lulls you you know
what I mean because he kind of plays
that game where he kind of acts like
he's not as intelligent as he is right
and then he yeah he [__] like he his
arguments are usually pretty Flawless
you know yeah he's a master debater for
sure it's weird
[Laughter]
or a masturbator yeah there's just weird
yeah man and you know we've we have uh
talked about this topic to like
exhaustion right but 136 mass shootings
and it's only what April yeah
and look why does it happen because we
have that many [__] guns in this
country yeah look at the [__] numbers
let's get the data look at the
statistics we're by far and wide have
the most shootings than any other
developed country out there yeah like
it's not even close the second country
is not even close it's like a bar like
this to like like that you know
what's the common denominator here what
the [__] do you think yeah what other
people other and we said this before
other countries don't have mentally ill
people yeah other countries don't have
crazy people other countries don't have
problems other countries don't have
people with gripes and issues no they
[__] do but they don't [__] have
access to Firearms the way the United
States does and it's kind of interesting
too I feel I don't feel I know like
passing your driver's license is hardly
getting your gut dude it's all right
depending also on which DMV you go to
because some DMVs like the instructor
the driving instructors are a
[__] you know they're super
picky and like got an attitude and my
first uh driving uh by when I went to
the DMV to do the test the first person
the [__] biggest [__] I have ever
met in my life you stank breath snackle
tooth hoe I [__] hate it you know
what it is bro
it's a Power Trip they have that little
bit of power and it goes to their head
and they're on it you know she [__]
failed me dude I wanted to just
this [__] Jabba the Hutt looking
[__] sitting there just melting in her
[__] seat yeah just checking all this
other stuff well
I would normally let you pass this but
today I'm not in that mood think like
she would say [__] like that wow and I
sat here like I remember so the I went
to go take the test again right
and the the other driver instructor was
fine she was like oh you did a great job
and I'm like that's not what the last
lady told me and they're like they knew
who it was that dude knew who that
[__] lady was they're like oh you got
I forgot what her name was I was like
yeah how do you know where the light
listen
we don't even like her around here like
she's not you know she's been working
here for a long time she's not gonna get
fired like you know people whoever she
[__] fails everybody bro like um when
I was uh like getting my permit and
driver's license all that too um there
would be kind of like word spreading
around which DMV locations not to go to
because there's you know those
instructors there who are [__] and
like have uh it kind of are known to
fail people just because they're dicks
um so like you would avoid those DMVs to
go take the driver's test out and then
go to places that are known to be a
little bit more lenient or just normal
just have normal people without this
[__] SASS and attitude for nowhere
like that caterpillar from A Bug's Life
Dog I [__] hated her that looked like
the [__] Mucinex um
lady dude there's some people out there
who are so [__] miserable they just
will they just want everybody to be
miserable I know man I and look bro if
like whatever it is you're doing in your
life you [__] it makes you that
miserable and you hate it that much if
possible if possible because I know it's
not always possible
do something about it make a [__]
change instead of like [__] ruining
other people's day or trying to ruin
other people's actually you know what I
don't even know if it's a conscious
effort to like I'm gonna ruin somebody
else's day today and maybe it's just
they're so [__] miserable and they
hate their jobs hate their life so much
that that's their [__] attitude you
know it's weird man like and I'm pretty
sure a lot of people have been around
these type of people where if you
haven't if you achieve something great
in your life right or if you are happy
they always have like some type of weird
side comment to say when you know they
make it it's like in guise of them
trying to celebrate you but it sounds
salty for sure it's not funny like a
backhanded compliment at best right at
best I hate those type of people dude I
mean but the thing is bro especially
these days you know in the age of social
media everybody has something to say
right oh everybody does yeah doc there's
there's somebody that I had to cut out
uh in the last year where this guy so
[__] annoying every time you meet
this dude right he would just he's
either complaining about his wife or his
kids right and I'm like Doug
should you be saying this [__] about
your [__] family to us you know what
I mean yeah it's like oh man my [__]
kids this and that oh my wife oh but she
doesn't do this I'm like you're kind of
an [__] dog I wouldn't want to be
married to you either you [__] dick
yeah you know and this guy it's like the
problem with people like that too is
that it's always everybody else's fault
it's not theirs exactly so no matter
what happens to them there's no personal
responsibility it's not oh okay maybe I
shouldn't have said this this and that
right this guy I have literally had to
check his ass in public at like dinners
because of the way that he would like
speak to his wife in front of us because
I'm not trying to stand up for his wife
I'm more like likely just trying to
enjoy my meal
about something else bro how about that
like it would be like personal
relationship stuff that he should be
keeping between him and his wife but
he's putting it out for us at this table
or or [__] be talking to like a
marriage counselor about you know doc
he's so [__] dumb this guy's so
stupid
that I remember that he so he comes up
he goes yeah I'm finally talking to a
therapist I'm like that's funny because
you're staying still the same piece of
[__] right I'm like oh what am I what
did your therapist say and he starts
going into all this weird mysticism [__]
I'm like wait who is your therapist he's
like it's my chiropractor I'm like dog
I'm literally gonna stab you
no no I'm dead seriously I'm dead
serious he said it's
I mean was he serious though it was dead
this is how dumb he's dumb
he said his chiropractor so it's his
therapist so he just decides I'm gonna
give him that title and then yes that's
the reality now that's the truth yes
that's how insane he is you know at
first it was entertaining yeah now it's
just like you need to leave me you need
to get the [__] out of my life wow this
is my fault too because I tend to like
really weird people yeah and at first
it's funny but then when it comes to
stuff like that I'm like oh you need to
be cut out no but the thing is I like
weird people too I mean [__] you know
you know me I'm [__] weird myself
right but you gotta kind of draw the
line on that weirdness and if somebody's
telling me their chiropractor is their
therapist my fir I mean I might give
them the benefit of Doubt like oh so
your chiropractor is also a licensed
therapist no just my chiropractor my
chiropractor that's that's it who does
like Asian misses that type of stuff I
don't care if the me like I just got my
plate I'm getting up to go box place I'm
out of there this guy is so [__]
weird too like he has a problem he's so
dumb he actually doesn't what we found
out too is he would use words that he
doesn't know what they mean and then he
would get mad at us for not
understanding what the [__] he's saying
and the problem with somebody that
stupid is that they think that they're
smart right well see that's that's when
it gets like infuriating is that when
they're not
you know their their IQ is not too high
but they think they are they're
delusional into thinking that they're
very intelligent and every [__] you
know word that comes out of their mouth
should be gospel that's that's when it's
crazy people say some [__] like
I'll get that to you ASAP in about four
weeks I'm like hold on a second hey
[__] what do you think ASAP
stands for
sex
as soon as possible
oh I didn't know I was like so you just
you just say words no so you didn't even
know what [__] ASAP stood for so
he'll hear other people say words that
he thinks is really smart oh you cannot
be serious this guy's not real bro
not like dog that is crazy you know she
understand for a weird person like me
being around somebody like this is very
entertaining what
you know when it started to come into a
part where it was very toxic I was like
okay now you gotta go
understand you know from my perspective
you got to know why I keep this guy
around that's [__] hilarious it is
funny it is funny I'm not gonna hey I'm
not gonna [__] lie bro I've dated
girls too where I'm like oh man I'm
about to stick my dick into some crazy
but just out of curiosity just just to
see like how like I already know she's
crazy I wanna there's a [__] weird
part of me that wants to know how crazy
are you though and then once I see that
I'm like yup that's what I thought and
then I'm [__] out of there once once
once it got to the point with this
individual where we figured out that he
just you know he's kind of a downer to
be around because he wants everybody to
pity him he wants everybody think that
he's the hardest working person in the
[__] room everything's a dick
measuring contest we're like oh now you
gotta go because before it was just
funny Mr ASAP
ASAP yeah that's his [__] nickname
you know for me too like you got to
understand like when you're that [__]
dumb of course I'm gonna make fun of you
all the time yeah this fool came out to
me he goes like what do you always make
fun of me
well here's the thing though to to his
defense I mean even though I don't want
to defend a dude like that in his mind
there's nothing wrong that he's doing
exactly he has no [__] key why you're
being so mean he doesn't even get the
joke yeah he doesn't understand because
he thinks he's the smartest person I'm
like holy [__] you're [__] dumb bro I
mean look bro if he's like that not
self-aware how can he possibly
understand that you're joking to him
it's just you're being mean oh you're
just bullying him you know and like
everybody's thinking that he understands
the jokes but he doesn't get and I'm
like oh you're like when
what I basically said he was dumb people
think it's an insult no I don't mean
that as an insult I I'm factually
stating it's a matter of fact that he is
actually stupid he's like I'm not sure
if anybody out there has actually met
somebody who's legit dumb oh yeah like
holy [__] you're actually dumb I mean
you get dumbfounded because you're like
I cannot believe the [__] words that
are coming out of your mouth right now
yeah but that is fascinating and and
that's the part where it like it it
triggers us that it triggers that
[__] curiosity let me see how how
deep this hole goes like there's there's
like a like a Litany of things that I
have where this guy has says has used a
word where I just knew it by the Blank
Stare in his eyes that he didn't know
what that word meant but he wanted to
use it because he wanted to sound like
he was smart and it's very funny when
you see somebody do that he'll be like
like for example like ASAP he goes I'll
get that to you ASAP happened four weeks
and you have to pause and think he
doesn't know what the word ASAP is it's
like it's like Z saying all the crazy
[__] except Z's not dumb he's Swedish
exactly he doesn't know the American you
know slang and culture but like he kind
of hears it
regurgitates it and it comes out in this
funky way in his Swedish brain into like
you guys will find out too having people
that stupid around you is actually very
dangerous like you can't trust these
type of people oh I wouldn't I wouldn't
never you can't trust them with [__]
anything yeah they tend to be pretty
conniving because they don't understand
like they have zero empathy because in
their mind they can rationalize every
bad thing that they do right because
they're always right yeah I mean that's
just you know that's usually a separate
toxic trait but like when you combine
all of those toxic traits together into
one entity this very fascinating black
hole of a human being Mr ASAP
that's that's when it's yeah you're done
yeah I gotta draw that line here there's
like so many other stories that I have
with this person like I can't even
remember them but I had them written
down on my phone because how hilarious
it is because it's like scriptworthy
things like this Michael Scott from the
office oh my God
because it's funny to watch it from the
outside right right but you know
everybody in the office had to deal with
this terrible mom yeah no no that I I've
heard people say multiple times that
they can't watch the office because
they've had a manager or a bus like
Michael Scott and it's just too real for
them like it infuriates them and so it's
like the comedy doesn't come across it's
like no [__] this guy like I used to I
used to [__] work under a guy like
this you know I don't know man it's my
fault though I'd be giggling and
laughing at people too much it makes me
very entertaining no you're too curious
that's the problem just like me man I
told you you know my curiosity has
definitely got me into binds just
because like and and I know I know I'm
putting myself in a precarious situation
but like the Curiosity gets the best I
just gotta I gotta scratch that itch you
know and then once that itch is
scratched though I'm like okay you know
what like what what else did I expect
yeah yeah yeah and then there have been
times where it's more than I bargained
for where of course yeah I'm like okay
that that met my curiosity and then so
now you got to cut them out yeah yeah
but this this weekend was um
I know a lot of you may not watch MMA
but okay so I was at okay first of all
let me tell you this this thing that
[__] happened right so I was at the
uh Brandon Lee if you don't know who
Brandon Lee is Brandon Lee is a half
Mexican half Korean kid uh super young
in his younger 20s uh so far undefeated
28-0 and I got invited out to go uh
watch his fight in this private little
Suite it's cool Barton over there right
bro
you listen it was either that or the UFC
fight
so we were at we were there and then
let me tell you something
if you guys have never seen like
Fighters fight in real life it's very
different from TV if you think they're
fast on TV when you see it in person you
literally don't know what the [__] is
happening and you know for me because
I've watched so much boxing when you
watch amateur boxers you can kind of
already tell what's gonna happen in the
fight right and I watched a lot of
boxing in the last year or two and so I
was with Khalif and I was like literally
telling Khalif I'm like that guy's gonna
get knocked out probably in the second
round if not the first and then like all
these younger fighters who are Pros but
you could tell they're beginners I
called every every way the fight was
going to be stopped I called it 10 for
10. yeah but then when it started
getting into the main card with high
level people I couldn't see [__] yeah
I'm like I don't know what the [__] is
happening I don't know who's hitting
what I don't know who's rolling what and
then you know people are screaming I'm
like what are you screaming and I they
were what because you know we're in the
suite you can't even see what they're
getting hit with because they're so
[__] fast but there was one pro fight
that was not on the card They had in
between waiting for the for the main car
to start it was these two heavyweights
and Khalif is watching this fight
Cleveland doesn't watch a lot of
fighting and I said
okay these are two heavyweights they're
both overweight the other guy's super
[__] overweight and he looks
overweight in a sloppy type of way and
his technique was super sloppy yeah I'm
like he's going to overthrow that guy's
gonna knock him out guess what happens
in like the first round yeah he
overthrows the guy slips and he [__]
likes Francis and ganu uppercuts the
living life out of him and then he falls
out and like Million Dollar Baby his
head falls out of the ring and it snaps
oh [__] so we thought he died Yeah we
actually thought he died yeah because he
could not move he wouldn't he was out
cold he was out cold so imagine the ring
and his neck snap right back right and
so they had to put a brace on him and
they had to stretch this like 270 pound
dude out I thought he died dude yeah
like it's crazy to me like when you're
fighting at a high level right whether
it's their good or not high level
meaning a pro boxing level yeah don't
you think you would dedicate your life
to not getting killed
this book came out titties swinging yeah
right
sloppy as [__] I'm like why the [__] do
you want to be a boxer if you're not
gonna dedicate yourself to this [__]
sport yeah you know but sometimes
physique can be uh deceiving right I'm
100 yeah
and like the biggest like tell sign that
you could see for heavyweights who
aren't really good at that low level is
that when they're super out of shape and
you could already in the first 30
seconds that guy's hands were down to
his waist for sure it wasn't him trying
to [__] Rope A Dope wasn't him trying
to shoot low Jabs yeah it wasn't his
style it was straight up because he was
tired first 30 seconds he couldn't keep
his hands up I'm like oh you're one of
those out of shape heavyweight exactly
you look at a guy like Tyson Fury who
does not have the best physique amazing
the reason why he's in the position he's
in and has you know the um the accolades
that he does is because he [__]
dedicates himself to the crap cause I'm
not saying that if you're big you can't
be a great right I'm saying everything
else has to be that much better exactly
exactly but but you know that's a
difference that you're you're
establishing right now is that you can
look out of shape but like if you're not
putting into work that's going to show
real quick exactly and that dude first
30 second was gassed yeah gassed out of
his mind and I'm like dog you're going
in there to get your face smashed in and
heavyweights hit hard yeah that dude I'm
pretty sure I I think from what I saw
they thought that he was paralyzed
because he couldn't move his legs holy
[__] it was that [__] bad dog yeah so
that's that's [__] scary man scary as
[__] I literally thought I witnessed
somebody die yeah but Brandon Lee came
out with a W but during that time you
know the arasanya fight was happening
UFC 287 yeah and you have to understand
something right if you have never
watched the fight before right watch
every press conference and everything
else leading up to arasanya and
beheada's first fight and second fight
because the story behind it was so
[__] powerful listen I was watching
the boxing match and I out of respect I
didn't watch the UFC 287 while the
boxing match was happening right I'll be
honest it's very interested in the
boxing match
because I wanted to watch UFC 287 yeah I
mean I was [__] hyped up for that so
little Jason Chen was there yeah tiny
little Jason Chen and I grabbed his tiny
little shoulders because he was watching
it yeah and I was like don't you [__]
say anything yeah he goes okay but he's
got like shut the [__] up yeah don't say
[__] Jason I [__] love you yeah but
don't say [__] so I'm driving and I'm
watching the fight as I'm driving better
so I literally I see it going okay I'm
too excited I pull over yeah and I'm on
the side of the street and I'm watching
it and then I witnessed [__] history
yeah it is insane in the emphatic
fashion in which adesanya beat pejera
background story arasanya has kickboxed
professionally right amazing Phenom has
fought twice in kickboxing and lost to
him twice right first time he fought him
he should have won he won that [__] I
watched that [__] so many times even
before I knew who uh decision was yeah
that was a terrible decision there's not
a single person who watches that
kickboxing match and agrees that they
had a one yeah right second time
adesanya basically almost knocks his ass
out he gave him the he got saved by the
standing a count dog the ref [__]
stopped him in between yeah when he's
about when he's about to connect yeah
and then he breaks it up I'm like hold
on a second what the [__] was that yeah
so he got saved and then bejeda knocks
out assignments
terrible terrifying left hook and
adesanya was [__] him up yeah he was
he was he was winning the fight for sure
same thing in the third one so Pera
comes over
to the UFC well before he even talking
about him coming the reason why he did
come to chase odessanya was because
arasanya [__] was said nobody even
knows who the [__] this guy is yeah like
this guy is still living in the past
talking about me like I'm way past that
I'm a [__] Champion now he got
motivated he said oh yeah
all right we're gonna [__] see so how
does Sonia is saying that drove him to
come chase him so he comes over
to the UFC finds out of Sanya he beats
strict uh Sean Strickland yeah he's a
top 10 uh middleweight yeah an emphatic
fashion knocks him [__] out yeah
basically he's knocking everybody the
[__] out flying knees would you name it
right
um they get matched up which is and
let's let's see if Izzy credit there he
fast tracked him to a title fight right
yeah I mean it's great for him it's it's
for it's a way for him to kind of submit
his legacy yeah wins by TKO right in
this five round fight in which app
honestly I decided it was only four
rounds to five yeah right and in the
fifth round he [__] tkos aresanya now
arguably says that I was still awake
right
okay like it's hard for me to see that
yeah because he was he was getting
cracked like a [__] yeah maybe
out of Sonya he was still conscious yeah
yeah maybe I think there's a there's an
opening to say he could have pulled it
out right oh 100 100 so we never would
have known right maybe he would have
clinched them up taking him to the
ground maybe he would have done
something to survive that round right
even if he did get beat up but he
survived that round he still would have
retained his belt yeah right so arasanya
having defended his belt consistently
six or seven times at that point yeah
loses his belt to this guy who has
haunted him from his kickboxing career
all the way to the UFC spanning like
what [__] 15 years yes fighting or
some [__] you know
and so now arasanya has come back and
everybody was doubting him right there
was they were clowning him so hard bro
they were clowning the [__] out of him
and here's the thing what I really loved
about this too right was everything
leading up to this fight if you ever
wanted to be motivated to go go for
something in your life you should watch
this fight because arasanya now is the
underdog not even on the betting cards
he wasn't he wasn't yeah but you know
just the the conversation that was
happening around him yeah it was like
almost a foregone conclusion like yeah
everybody wrote him like dude do you
guys not remember what the [__] this guy
has done I wrote him off too listen
the only reason why yeah but there was
so at this point I really thought that
pejeta was going to beat arasanya and it
was from a conversation that Peta said
Peter was talking to an interviewer
somebody was interviewing him he says
listen
there's certain people in your life that
you will just never ever beat right he
goes when I was fighting professional
kickboxing there was a guy that I could
not beat and in fact he hasn't been
kickboxing or fighting in years but if
he and I stepped into this ring right
now he would beat me again I am that
person for arasanya he is that person
for Robert Whittaker he will never beat
me yeah and I took that [__] to heart
but then I saw this interview
it was at the at the the pre-fight
conference and he goes he's like he's
looking at the camera and he looks like
a crazy person yeah he looks deranged
yeah he goes everybody's doubting me
because what if I knock him the [__] out
what if I did I looked at him like I
think I was not just gonna win from that
look yeah because he looked hungry he
had that fire in his eyes he'd look
possessed for sure he looked [__]
insane yeah this [__] was
speaking Nigerian and all this other
[__] I was like God damn he looks like
the [__] Warrior yeah right well
that's why he kept saying now the
hunters become the hunted you know yeah
just this whole Saga the whole story
behind it man it's [__] epic this man
just hunted Izzy down and stripped his
belt from him and the way in which is he
won it wasn't a few touches it was a
rope-a-dope Against the Cage overhand
right into a [__] hook yeah to a
[__] Thor's hammer fist right to him
from the gods he said Hammer Fist from
the gods you know and then he knocks him
out with the arrow dude that was the
most [__] epic like finishing move
bro you know I was like wow bro I was in
the car I teared up yeah no for I got I
got I'm not gonna lie I got a little
choked up too I don't tear up but I got
chocolate you know heartless son of a
[__] I teared up dog watching him win
made me feel like I could do anything
and and the post-conference speech you
know or in post-fight speech how amazing
was that and he pulled that [__] right
out of his ass Joe Rogan never gives him
the mic ever ever but he said to him
respectfully Joe like I just got
something to say I'll give them my right
back Joe didn't even hesitate he's like
here you go I've never seen Joe I've
seen people trying to take the mic away
from him he has that iron grip on it
you're not taking that from Joe you know
like that speech was so [__]
important because I think that it's like
he was he was basically saying that you
know there are these moments in your
life that makes life worth living right
but you have to be the one to go out
there and find it you gotta go for it
yeah and he goes this is that moat for
me he goes I get to relive these moments
over and over again but this is what you
should be fighting for you need to make
this [__] happen for yourself right and
these moments exist for you that [__]
made me [__] feel amazing yeah and
it's been hard to describe to people
what I mean by like when I get something
I get it done I move on to the next one
because I want is because that's what I
chase all the time yeah I chase for that
[__] feeling right whether it was in
the film whether it was in YouTube to
podcasting all the way to you know
clothing with secret society jumbi
matcha I've done this multiple times and
I'm trying to do it over and over again
right and it doesn't matter what it is
it's just whatever I choose it to be
yeah and like that's the thing that I
feel like people kind of miss when they
try things out right they forget that
there is this feeling that you get when
you are high highly successful as
something that people feel like you
cannot do yeah and that was amazing
right how he won was [__] insane you
couldn't have written it better you
really couldn't have written it better
it was so [__] epic probably one of
the most epic like story lines that I've
witnessed in my life when it comes to
MMA right I can't think of anything
that's more
um
I I again using the word epic more epic
than that you know it it was just a
[__] incredible start to finish and I
think that speech was so important for
the reasons you just mentioned but also
serving as a reminder for the young kids
the Young Generation in this day and age
where they only see the end result and
they think it's so easy to achieve no it
was important for him to mention like
you going for it you can't just expect
this to happen you can't think that it's
easy right he put in the [__] work he
Dro he said he's drove himself to like
the brink of insanity you know to to
make sure that he was prepared and he
needed to get to where he needed to be
to put this guy down the way he did you
know and he has his channel uh the
freestyle bender on YouTube so like he
he doesn't need to be talking about it
but there's documentation you could see
the training and the work that he's
putting in to get to where he is and
that's a very important reminder it's
like don't forget what you gotta do to
get to that result to find to find find
that happiness to achieve that moment
the work needs to [__] be there and I
feel like a lot of times in this day and
age there's that gap between wanting
something and the result yeah and you
forget that whole [__] middle part
yeah it was just like how Picture
Perfect of a moment could that have been
man and how symbolic for him how how
relieved do you think he felt he goes
not by decision Yeah by [__] he sent
him to the shadow Realms you know that
[__] woke up in [__] wakanda
dude definitely woke up whenever
somebody wakes up with the angry face
you know because when he got up he was
like yeah you know they were not came
back from the shadow realm bro that is
like a sign of a vicious knockout
gold dude cause that first and the thing
is I was talking to you about the same
way that he almost knocked him out
exactly in the first fight and and it
almost was how Izzy got [__] TKO in
the first fight right it looked eerily
the [__] same except this time Izzy
had that extra five seconds you guys
have to watch how beautiful that [__] is
right so he's literally pressed up
against this cage yeah yeah his guard is
high yeah he's getting hit but he's
looking he's awake liver shot knee up
the middle yeah and he's getting a
little bit cut a hook yeah and then he
gets shifted off the side and then Izzy
waits for the small eyes that opening
and the he does his small little check
hook right yeah so the check hook lifts
yeah let's hit his chin up yep and then
the overhand connects he throws Alex
Panda's head into his overhang right and
right to the [__] Temple yeah if
you've never been hit the temple before
like your whole equilibrium goes off
it's really weird like the dude his body
went like this and then it came back up
the the feeling is weird like it just
feels odd you can't really describe it
but the whole room starts to stop it's
like vertigo yeah you've ever
experienced vertical before he's falling
right he's falling and he connects
another hook yeah right pink the thing
is he [__] bounced himself off the
cage to get that extra momentum for you
know and that one landed flush on the
ear so like that that was it he was Alex
his or Alexis lights were turning out as
he was falling and then as soon as he
landed the [__] hammer fish from the
gods and then out Supernatural yeah
super necessary that was super necessary
it goes up to his kid and he goes hey
hey look
he said
he mentioned that too he's like dude I'm
just being petty I'm a [__] Petty
person I had to do it I [__] love
that moment man yeah listen fight fan or
not you should just watch that trilogy
to or the not the TR I guess it's a
quadrilogy yeah but watch all the UFC
embeds that led up to that to give you
the backstory of how satisfying that is
and I guarantee you if you don't wake up
motivated tomorrow you are a loser right
there's no [__] one and this like his
speech really transfers over to
everything that you do in life it's so
oh for sure [__] good Universal and
that's why he asked Joe for the mic and
the thing is Izzy said like he didn't
even have that speech prepared yeah he
just in that moment he got to say what
he felt yeah exactly dog it was it was
so [__] beautiful man I gotta tell
you dude I never want to be a fighter
for sure I don't ever watch that to say
I want to fight I [__] pulled my
oblique kicking a bag the other day that
[__] [__] hurt that's your Alexa
foreign
there was a guy who was a PT that was
speaking to my comments he goes That's
like a five-week injury dude like you
gotta chill yeah [__] man because it
hurt in that video right when I threw it
and by the way I threw my whole [__]
whole life into that low kick wow and it
was beautiful sat back down and then
but see that's the thing man you know we
keep learning this the hard way over and
over as we get older you know we're
knocking on 40s door right like you you
you you
[Laughter]
forget in your mind that you know you're
a little bit older a little bit more
fragile and you still think you could do
the same thing that you did even a year
ago or two years ago and you learned
real quick that [__] humbles you
real quick like now not even that old
dog I'm 35 son
dog I [__] threw my life force into
that kick dog and then I just felt this
sharp ass pain I couldn't breathe and
I'm like oh I think I tore something and
that [__] hurt so [__] bad hey man
I'm [__] dealing with the injured
shoulder that I heard somehow from
sleeping I don't even know how the [__]
that happened bro oh you old
I got my ass beat by a punching bag at
least it was worse I got my ass beat by
my pillow well speaking of [__] uh
Israel
Israel adesanya man we all know Israel
yet like it's so crazy how he just like
derives a lot of his strength for
[__] Naruto right and I don't give a
[__] what any [__] weeb says to me
right Naruto is not that great of a
[__] anime you [__] all
right you little [__] get mad at me
for saying this one that's coming from a
big anime fan I haven't watched listen
I'm such a big anime fan I have watched
one piece since the first [__]
episode right and I love Naruto growing
up right I know he's doing all these
Rock Lee references whatever whatnot
yeah Naruto had its moments but the
shitty thing about Naruto was that 80
fillers 20 episodes and the animation
unless it was a very important episode
was [__] trash it just carried on too
long it was about a young boy that
wanted to [__] his best friend
I just I just got over it I got [__]
over it yeah I never got into Naruto too
it was it because look you got to watch
300 episodes of pure nonsense right and
then you'll get to watch some of the
greatest episodes you'll ever see in
your life in terms of animation
for maybe 10 episodes right which sucks
but speaking of one of my favorite
animes of all time
story wise just the antagonist the
protagonist everything about this is a
classic is [__] Death Note oh man
yeah if you haven't watched you could
watch it on Netflix because it's on
Netflix not not the live action one guys
don't at least I'll never watch that the
actual anime watch the anime
Death Note was is a thriller right I'm
not gonna ruin it or spoil it if you
haven't watched it and if you're an
anime fan you have definitely watched
death note that is in the Lexicon of one
of the greatest short series animes of
all time like yeah top five like it's
not even arguable yeah you know easily
so
I've teased this before
um every genius brain secret society
release that we do you know it's kind of
hard to I don't want to say top the
previous one right because they're all
different they're very important like
little parts of my life
this one right here as you see this one
back here was inspired by the trip to
Korea right right
um so it plays a very important role in
my life anime was a big part of my life
and still is till this day and one of
the hardest things that I find is to not
find a generic anime t-shirt right that
just number one or just not a non-gotty
design exactly it's like sometimes they
try to do too much way too much yeah so
in Ode to my like love for anime growing
up into one of the best animes of all
time that also works with like the
secret society aesthetic we're doing a
Death Note secret society genius brain
collab I [__] love this [__] so
[__] much yeah this one obviously I
love to and by the way if you ever
[__] deny the quality of these are
[__] this has been washed like [__]
20 times yeah and look at this goddamn
thing yeah if you take care of our stuff
it lasts forever always make sure to
follow the care instructions we always
have them listed on the uh the listing
itself or the items but yeah kind of
going back to what you're talking about
with with this collaboration you know
Dave and I were talking about kind of
the next iteration right of of the
genius brain collab what what is it
going to look like are we going to
continue off the Korean Heritage thing
are we going to do something completely
different and so you know we we always
start at like the basics and and the
basics is what inspires you you know it
because it has to draw out from that
that's the biggest thing it has to be a
something that impacts your life that's
been an inspiration
um at some point in your life whether
it's you know from the beginning or or
as you got older right but it has to
have a big enough impression on you
where it's like yeah it's that important
to me and then we started talking about
anime you know yes and by the way I
think one of the the things that like
secret society does really well is like
we kind of filled the gap between the
like a lot of the things that people
want to have but they don't have the
quality that you want for it every
[__] anime shirt that I've had right
is the shittiest [__] t-shirt I've
ever had so disappointing man so bad
because I have a Cowboy Bebop T right
I was like dude this is actually a
pretty dope design but like they [__]
up on the print color the T-shirt
quality is scratchy yeah she is a
[__] the fit is weird I'm like
why you guys got to do it like like come
on man like pay homage proper homage
like you're doing this okay you know
what some people are just doing it to
[__] cash grab right but if you're
doing this because you really love
whatever series it is
pay proper homage to it man do it
[__] Justice you know
um and that's the thing I think at this
point people have come to expect like a
certain level of quality and uh
craftsmanship and attention to detail
from us right and that's something that
we try to always [__] go over again
and again and again fine tune it fine
tune it refine it and so
when we started talking about this idea
you know it was exciting because it's
like okay Death Note is like one of his
all-time favorites one of my all-time
favorites I'm sure a lot of people's one
of all time's favorites right but more
than that it's not like oh what are we
trying to do that's popular that people
like no no we personally like this [__]
so if you don't like it oh well but you
know that's that's a big reason why
we're doing it and it's like okay so how
are we gonna marry that you know
um that the genius brain aspect of it in
the secret society aspect of it and then
come up with an aesthetic that fits in
line right with the brand that that
accommodates both brands
and I feel like we [__] nailed them
we have a sample here yeah so we have a
sample on one it says throw away tea
this isn't the actual tea we just ran
this to see how it came because here's
the thing we had an idea for how we
wanted to do it which is the puff print
and we thought the details that we have
in the illustration and and design the
puff print would really [__] make
this pop and so we we ran a sample this
is the very first sample [__] maybe
we'll even do a giveaway on this like as
as like a Sentimental piece yeah yeah
this is the very first sample that we
ran
um and we will start with the front here
you guys may have seen this logo that we
told uh teased toast
that we teased
um yeah you got the secret society
genius brain and you got ryukir you know
that's his outline got me the definition
yeah and then
boom that's just so [__] stupid like
that
look at this [__] it's all puff print by
the way which is [__] very difficult
yeah
intricate the [__] is yeah pretty much
all the main characters are here
um and then we got numbers here and then
we have yeah the logos again here but
this [__] looks [__] incredible and
when you guys see it in person too like
it pops in a different way and once
again of course it's going to be the the
dopest shirts right quality is going to
be amazing same as if you if you've got
your hands on the
God I love this shirt if you got your
hands on this same quality tea
um
like that in and of itself is going to
be probably the best like anime inspired
shirt that you'll ever [__] have oh
yeah I mean it's I mean come on man
honestly like objectively if I was not
involved I said the same [__] about that
objectively if I was not involved and I
saw somebody wearing that I'd be like yo
that's [__] dope yep like I I'm sorry
it's it's [__] dope and we have this
uh we're gonna have the black on white
and then also a white on black two
colorways like we did uh last time and
we're also gonna have hats how many hats
that is TBD we don't know exactly yet
we're gonna have two colorways a black
one and then
um a black white one yeah like like we
did with the genius brand but they're
gonna be trucker foam truckers this time
around because we were thinking too like
what
um what style of hat would best
complement uh what we're doing with the
designs and and the look The look and
feel we're going for and the foam
truckers work the best
you guys will see why why we decided to
go with that because those we're gonna
run a sample
um today is uh Wednesday right so I
think sometime next week we're gonna see
a sample because we want to do something
specific on it and we don't know if it's
gonna work yet but if it does work
so for these two um these are all going
to be pre-orders
um yeah we're gonna run it the exact
same way that we did with the first one
yeah we're gonna give you well our
subscribers first of all are gonna get
the dips they're gonna get the Early
Access with the pre-orders and then
we'll open it up
um we don't know exactly how the
pre-orders are gonna run just yet like
we got to figure that out and then we
got to figure out the timeline because
we don't know we don't know exactly what
the production schedule is going to look
like yet
um but that all make sure you subscribe
and and we'll definitely give you guys
an update on it once we figure those
things yeah if you're on the email list
you you guys get first dibs on
everything so when uh it's kind of a way
for us to just make sure the people who
[__] with us get the stuff first right
um obviously we're not a huge company so
when things run out of sizes people will
wear the sizes you didn't sign up for
the email yeah you didn't sign the
[__] [__] email everybody's gonna
take the [__] and so that's kind of
what's been happening yeah um and and
look we're trying yeah it's not like
we're we're not on this oh you know
we're trying to limit things no we just
have limited resources so there's only
so many things we can do yeah and so
many pieces we can make right yeah and
when we're trying to do like you know a
full-on collection with multiple colors
multiple designs like multiple bodies
you can't run thousands of pieces on
each we we just don't have that type of
resource hopefully we will we will you
know but and I love like the whole anime
thing too because like you know when I
was younger like
you know anime wasn't big man and if you
watched anime people talked about that
yeah like a [__] geek yeah secret
society is what we did yeah
you needed to be in a secret society too
exactly so it was like one of those
things that wasn't really popular right
but then the people who really loved it
they loved it a lot now obviously I'm
not as listen I thought I was a big
anime fan until I went to like an Anime
Con oh and I found out that I come I am
not I am nothing I thought I was a big
anime fan and I couldn't I you ain't
about that life though I'm not I'm not
like that and look I [__] loved going
to that thing because it was weird but I
like watching them all be so happy as
they got to connect with all their other
friends who were like super into this
[__] because I feel like you know how
much they're into it it gets made fun of
like if they're walking around in public
with like [__] bunny ears yeah you
know what I mean and then you know they
got like a Naruto costume on this is a
little weird right but if they're in
their element at this Anime Expo or the
Anime Con they feel [__] and yeah you
get to share with other people who are
just as passionate and love and and not
be judged for it you know what I mean I
always say man if it's not illegal and
you're not hurting anybody else hey do
you you don't do what makes you happy
man and and it's like yeah when I see
that
I know what you're talking about like
I'm not about that life but when I see
it I'm like hey I'm happy for you yeah
man so like anime always play like a
super like really fun important part of
my life even like the way I see film and
the things that I like it just kind of
like seeped into everything that I did
so what are the better ways to do it
than do it with this piece now every
time that we bring out a piece I don't
know what the next one is going to be
but this one yeah I think I think it's
good though that we have that pressure
on ourselves because the thing is I mean
it's that's a pretty much a standard for
us anyway you want to constantly like
keep uh elevating and try to do better
you know bigger better but especially
with these because their capsule
collection and it's limited to just like
you know one body with like two colors
you gotta it needs to hit right whereas
like in a full collection you might have
10 15 different pieces with all these
different colors something might hit
from that you have a higher chance but
then with this it's like that's the
design and that's the cool thing too
like with this with this I feel
you know evidently too this is genius
brain merchandise right but it's kind of
not at the same time it's like this it's
kind of its own thing or if you did walk
around the street somebody wouldn't look
at that like it's an animation even if
they're not an anime fan right let's
play oh that's a [__] six shirt yeah
that's a don't [__] design exactly
and that's like kind of the objective
that I have for you know when we create
these things too I don't know how many
times somebody has stopped and asked me
where they got the shirt it's the
capsule collection it's like it's not
going to come out again I'm sorry yeah
um maybe we will but this was a [__] to
make so don't ask
um I got PTSD yeah this is a PTSD the
[__] hard this [__] is
um PTSD from it but listen the
pre-orders for this uh we'll leave it
open what like two weeks was it two
weeks last time
um yeah I believe I believe we'll do two
weeks like we'll we'll work out the
details of it why are you not all the
details uh again just make sure you
subscribe to the newsletter and then
we'll shoot out all the details for you
guys you guys get the first dibs on it
and then you know we'll figure it out
yeah and the reason why you know people
are like why don't you put the pre-order
for like a month long well the longer
the pre-orders are the the hard longer
it takes for people to get there exactly
because it's made to order don't forget
that yeah you know that's why we're
doing a pre pre-order and then basically
making an order every single order and
that's why we set aside a certain amount
of time now the PTSD that we're
referring to with the first one was we
had issues with production and things
took much longer than anticipated kept
getting pushed back we don't foresee a
problem with this one
knock on it [__] everything here yeah
you know knock on wood that we don't
have any issues with this one so it
should be smoother
um but yeah like Dave just said you know
if the longer we have the window for it
takes that much longer for us to start
production and also two pre-orders for
us too it's just it's a lot easier in
terms of like number one resource wise
and number two this stuff is a little
more intricate than everything else so
we make this in Mass bulk and everything
gets [__] up like this one you guys
would have never gotten your shirts yeah
yeah so it kind of covers both of us
yeah it's it's better for better to
streamline for us this way you know so
that we find that pocket with our
Factory and just be like okay this is
what we're gonna run and just focus on
this for that time being to fulfill all
those orders and then yeah just pump it
out yeah so get ready for that
um that's going to launch pretty soon
we'll let you know just follow me on
Instagram follow Edge follow the secret
society page and then we'll let you all
know
um sign up for the email genius brain
every Sundays at 12 p.m and we will we
got the uh the exclusive genius brain
discount code this time too for viewers
we got the ssgb 20 for 20 off your order
no exclusions uh no minimums
one time use only though so if you're
watching this ssgb20 all capital letters
use it for 20 off and we're gonna run it
for about a week from when you see this
yes
um yeah so keep an eye out for that once
again sign up for the email
um I've I've literally talked to so many
people about this why how do I get to
know the email damage we actually have
two pieces here that will preview
um next time too this is coming from our
spring summer collection that's going to
be coming out like I don't know in a
couple of months or so but yeah these
are some exciting pieces yeah you spend
every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll see you
all next time peace